[Music]
what is happening in the West from
America through throughout sort of
Western and Eastern Europe it's it's a
fragmentation and a breakdown and the
successful parties are no longer to be
understood on the left-right spectrum
they're actually a mixture of left and
right there are socialists who believe
in leave there are socialists who
believe in remain but leave and remain
are now better predictors of who you're
going to vote for than your past tribal
identity so what's really happening is
is realignment and fragmentation and
largely speaking I want to suggest to
you that the formulation that's taking
place and I think you know you you got
it in one is nationalism on the one hand
and extreme liberalism understood as
identity politics on the other and I
won't suggest you that neither of them
ultimately in my view will work because
we have been governed by extreme
liberalism for really since since the
time of Margaret Thatcher you have
extreme economic liberalism on the right
extreme social liberalism on the left
and there a common project and I always
think it's incoherent to hear people on
the left's denouncing neoliberalism
economically but essentially upholding
it socially and and vice versa so what
is the liberal project that is now over
the liberal project is essentially a
grand global project of extreme
individualism and this grand global
project have first appealed to the
narcissism of the 1960s
and the genuine in Justices that the
1960s spoke to but what it creates is a
dispensation economically that only
favors those at the very very top if you
look at the global distribution the
famous elephant graph by
Branko Milanovic he shows that really
over the last 3040 years has been no net
gain for the vast majority of the
working population from globalization
and the gain has been for the working
class in the third world whereas the
working class and increasing the middle
class in the first world has seen no
genuine gain at all you've seen the rise
of rampant insecurity because insecurity
stems from Brampton - individualism and
we've created on the economic level
forms of insecurity that we're actually
unthinkable in the 60s or indeed the 70s
but on the cultural right and culture we
know outcompetes economics in any
assessment of human behavior liberalism
has essentially created a culture that
oppresses majorities that creates
marginalized majorities through identity
politics that are little more than
middle class power games and attempts by
middle class advocates to both virtue
signal and gain power within a medium
whereby solidarity has collapsed so
don't be surprised that nationalism is
on the way back because nationalism by
those who advocate for it is the only
thing that will care for them
nationalism by it from the perspective
it's of advocates is the only thing that
will care for those who have lost out
whereas liberalism won't liberalism of
of the extreme left has become an
upper-middle class project and so what
we've got is a project where solidarity
are looking after us all has been
captured by nationalism and the project
the right wing project of extreme
individualism is now followed by both
left-wing parties and right-wing parties
that is the new divide that is the new
debate that is where we are for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you